Sono più di 20 anni che lavoro come sviluppatore di software. Ho iniziato con lo scrivere
semplice codice fino ad arrivare ad oggi alla progettazione e realizzazione di interi prodotti
e servizi basati su web e cloud. Negli ultimi anni poi, credo un po' come tutti, ho incluso
nei miei processi di lavoro tutta una serie di strumenti basati sul Large Language Model
e devo dire che sono piuttosto contento dei risultati. Da un paio di mesi a questa parte,
però, mi sono piovuti addosso decine di articoli e post, tanti mi sono stati perfino condivisi
in privato, che parlano della nuova frontiera dello sviluppo software, il VibeCoding. Ora,
siccome di sviluppo software ho la presunzione di capirne un pochino, sono rimasto piuttosto
inorridito da alcune delle cose che ho letto e sentito. Quindi, ho deciso di prendere anche
io parte al discorso e di raccontarti un po' la mia opinione in merito. Sigla!
Benvenuti su Pensieri in codice, il podcast dove si ragiona da informatici, con Valerio Galano.
Oramai è un paradigma piuttosto consolidato. Ogni volta che salta fuori una novità tecnologica
di un certo rilievo, partono subito gli schieramenti. Da un lato c'è chi demonizza, non funzionerà
mai, ci toglierà il lavoro, sarà una bolla, eccetera. Dall'altro c'è invece chi osanna,
è una nuova frontiera, ci cambierà la vita, renderà obsoleto tutto il resto e così via.
Nel mezzo di tutto questo poi di solito restano quelli come me, e immagino anche come te,
che per quanto possibile cercano di ignorare entrambe le tifoserie e di farsi la propria
idea che solitamente risulta essere un po' più moderata. Ora, non so se perché si parla
di un argomento che conosco molto bene, ma nel caso del vibecoding, molto più che in
altri perlomeno, ho notato la forte presenza di un ulteriore gruppo di soggetti che si
esprimono sulla questione, quelli che non ci hanno capito niente. È da qualche settimana
ormai che si parla tanto sul web di questa nuova tecnologia di sviluppo del software
basata su intelligenza artificiale, tanto per cambiare, ma in molti, soprattutto tra
quelli che ne decantano i pregi, dimostrano a mio parere di non avere le idee chiare
su cosa effettivamente essa sia. Mi sono passati davanti vari articoli e post sul vibecoding e ho
letto cose che, onestamente, non stanno né in cielo né in terra. Col vibecoding passi
dall'essere programmatore a product engineer. Oppure il vibecoding consente alle persone di
altre discipline di diventare rapidamente programmatori. Ma no, col cavolo. Mi dispiace,
ma queste affermazioni semplicemente non sono vere. Chi le ha formulate o non ha capito di cosa
stava parlando, o peggio ancora, cerca di far passare un concetto falso, un po' di fuffa. Il
vibecoding ha un suo perché e forse anche una sua utilità, ma il discorso è, come al solito,
molto più complesso di quanto sembri. Quindi facciamo un bel respiro, cominciamo dal principio
e proviamo a procedere con ordine.
Innanzitutto, cominciamo col capire esattamente il significato della locuzione VibeCoding.
La definizione è stata formulata per la prima volta da Andrej Karpati, sperando che si pronunci
così, che ha un dottorato alla Stanford University in Deep Learning, oggi lavora presso Eureka
Labs AI e in passato è stato direttore AI di Tesla e fondatore di OpenAI. Quante AI?
Insomma, uno che di intelligenza artificiale da un lato sicuramente ne capisce, ma dall'altro
ha anche tutto l'interesse a fare notizia. Ad ogni modo la storia inizia da un suo tweet
del 3 febbraio in cui racconta di questo suo nuovo modo di approcciarsi allo sviluppo del
codice.
C'è un nuovo tipo di programmazione che io chiamo Vibe Coding, in cui ci si abbandona
completamente alle vibrazioni, si abbracciano gli esponenziali e si dimentica che il codice
esiste.
Karpathy, con queste sue parole un po' zen, si riferisce al fatto che ormai alcuni ambienti
di sviluppo integrano dei large language model in modo sufficientemente avanzato da permettere
all'utente di chiedere di scrivere direttamente codice basandosi sull'intera codebase di un
progetto. In particolare, lui menziona l'editor cursor, i cui modelli generativi possono modificare
autonomamente il codice, e aggiunge perfino che utilizza Super Whisper che gli permette
di dialogare con il computer tramite la voce e non toccare quasi più la tastiera. Insomma,
cerca chiaramente di far subodorare un po' quel qualcosa di estremamente avveneristico
che abbiamo visto in tanti film di fantascienza, in cui l'operatore chiede al computer di fare
cose e quello esegue.
워싱턴에서 MBC 뉴스 이덕영입니다.
Chiedo le cose più stupide come diminuisci il padding della barra laterale della metà
perché sono troppo pigro per trovarlo.
Accetto sempre tutto, non leggo più le differenze.
Quando ricevo messaggi di errore, li copio e li incollo senza commenti, di solito questo
risolve il problema.
A volte i large language model non riescono a risolvere un bug, quindi mi limito ad aggirarlo
o a chiedere modifiche casuali finché non scompare.
Queste frasi rappresentano il vero cuore della definizione di VibeCoding, chiedere una modifica
all'AI e accettare l'output risultante acriticamente, senza nemmeno leggere il codice prodotto ma
integrandolo direttamente in quello esistente.
Come afferma lo stesso Carpathy, questo approccio il più delle volte funziona, e in caso di
problemi lui si limita a sottoporre gli errori allo stesso Large Language Model e integrare
direttamente l'eventuale soluzione proposta.
Tali operazioni vengono poi ripetute finché il problema in questione non viene risolto,
ed è questo che intende con abbracciare gli esponenziali.
Se poi, dopo un certo numero di iterazioni, diventa chiaro che non ci si sta avvicinando
all'obiettivo, Carpathy afferma che la soluzione può essere comunque trovata aggirando il
bug o chiedendo modifiche casuali a oltranza.
Non è male per i progetti da buttare giù nel fine settimana, ma comunque abbastanza
divertente.
Sto costruendo un progetto o una web app, ma non si tratta di vera e propria codifica.
Vedo solo cose, dico cose, eseguo cose e copio e incollo cose.
E per lo più funziona.
Lo sviluppo di software con l'assistenza dell'intelligenza artificiale esiste ormai
da qualche anno, e sappiamo da varie statistiche che è anche molto diffuso, ma con il VibeCoding
si ascende ad un livello successivo.
Con questo nuovo paradigma, il codice di fatto non viene più considerato, continua ad esistere
perché è un componente essenziale di qualsiasi software, ma lo sviluppatore, sempre se vogliamo
continuare a chiamarlo così, non vi accede più in alcun modo.
Al di là del sensazionalismo, però, frasi come «non è male per progetti del fine settimana»
e «per lo più funziona» dovrebbero già far capire che il VibeCoding non è la nuova
frontiera dello sviluppo software, quanto piuttosto un metodo accessibile per fare qualche
esperimento o poco più.
Tuttavia, sembra che in tanti, là fuori, nella foga di gridare al nuovo miracolo, che
ormai se non ne vediamo uno a settimana non siamo contenti, non siano neanche arrivati
a leggere il tweet fino in fondo.
O non lo abbiano capito, chissà.
il VibeCoding non è una nuova funzionalità degli ambienti di sviluppo o degli LLM, non
è un nuovo strumento e insomma non è un'innovazione, è semplicemente un modo diverso di utilizzare
una serie di tool che già esistevano e già utilizzavano in tanti. Probabilmente tra l'altro
c'è in giro tanta gente che già faceva VibeCoding senza che ancora a tale modus operandi fosse
dato il nome proprio da Carpati. Negli ultimi anni infatti sempre più sviluppatori hanno
iniziato ad utilizzare l'intelligenza artificiale per farsi assistere nella scrittura del codice,
scovare bug, ottimizzare le funzioni, implementare modifiche, nuove feature o anche solo farsi
suggerire strategie e idee. L'AI, forse più che in ogni altro campo, è diventata davvero
il copilota di quasi ogni sviluppatore. Nel corso di quest'ultimo paio d'anni poi l'approccio
si è anche notevolmente evoluto. Si è partiti da una fase iniziale nella quale si chiedeva
semplicemente a chatbot come chatGPT di scrivere o modificare uno snippet di codice. Successivamente
gli LLM sono stati integrati direttamente negli ambienti di sviluppo, in modo da dare
possibilità agli sviluppatori di dialogare con essi senza dover spostare l'attenzione su siti
o strumenti esterni. Poi sono giunte funzionalità avanzate che permettono ai modelli AI integrati di
manipolare direttamente il codice su ordine dello sviluppatore scrivendo e modificando i
file all'interno dei progetti. A tale livello l'LLM di turno analizza la richiesta del programmatore
e il codice disponibile e propone la sua soluzione mostrando le differenze tra l'implementazione
attuale e quella suggerita, lasciando all'umano la possibilità di accettarla, rifiutarla o volendo
modificarla. All'interno di tutto questo percorso di evoluzione il vibe coding è semplicemente un
approccio nel quale lo sviluppatore sceglie di accettare acriticamente il codice proposto
dalla macchina. L'umano quindi non fa revisione né tenta di raffinare l'output della macchina,
anzi non lo legge nemmeno. In pratica viene chiesto al modello di effettuare uno sviluppo
o una modifica e si prende subito il risultato per buono, passando direttamente a testarne il
funzionamento. Se vengono fuori dei problemi o degli errori li si riporta direttamente all'LLM
e gli si chiede di correggerli e di nuovo si accetta la correzione ad occhi chiusi. Quando
il problema è risolto si procede con la richiesta successiva e così via. Il processo di sviluppo
continua in questo modo finché non si è arrivati al risultato desiderato. Ora sorvolando su alcuni
aspetti pratici dei quali parleremo più avanti, un tale approccio visto dall'esterno sembra avere
una diretta implicazione, cioè se il processo di sviluppo di un software non concerne più il
controllare il codice allora diventa alla portata di chiunque. Tradotto, non serve più essere
programmatori o informatici per scrivere codice. Questo collegamento logico ha fatto scaldare
enormemente gli animi perché sembrerebbe spazzar via la necessità di un'intera categoria di
professionisti. C'è chi è arrivato a dire perfino che il business potrebbe sviluppare direttamente
i software in autonomia. Beh, non è esattamente così. Cominciamo a spiegare il perché dai motivi
oggetti e poi passiamo nel prossimo blocco ad alzare un po' l'asticella perché, come dire,
fatti non foste a vivere come bruti ma a perseguire virtute e canoscenza. Innanzitutto,
il solo fatto di pensare che si possa realizzare un software senza coinvolgere un soggetto che
abbia conoscenze di coding implica che esista qualcuno che abbia almeno un'idea da implementare.
Magari parliamo di un'azienda che vuole realizzare un servizio, di un manager che ha ideato un nuovo
strumento, una nuova feature o magari semplicemente di una persona qualunque che ha un problema da
risolvere. In ogni caso dovrebbe esserci un qualcuno che vuole avviare un business o un
progetto basandosi su una codebase interamente realizzata da una IA senza conoscere in alcun
modo il codice da essa sviluppato. Riformulo, stiamo parlando di andare in produzione con un
software di cui nessuno ha esaminato e validato il codice. I test effettuati nel VibeCoding infatti
saranno di tipo funzionale a salire, cioè riguarderanno l'utilizzo dell'applicazione e
non il codice come accadrebbe con unit o integration test. E non venirmi a dire che
l'IA potrebbe scrivere anche i test perché se comunque nessuno li esamina e li valida
siamo punti a capo, tanto vale chiedere all'hoste se il vino è buono. Ora ad essere onesti là fuori
c'è tanto codice che è tutt'oggi in funzione e che viene manutenuto da persone che non lo
hanno mai letto prima, in generale perché è stato sviluppato da altri che poi hanno cambiato
magari azienda o progetto, ma almeno una volta è passato al vaglio di un umano. Utilizzare invece
un codice mai verificato da nessuno è un qualcosa che onestamente da professionista non consiglierei
a nessuno dei miei clienti. Secondo un recentissimo studio che trovi in descrizione, infatti, gli
stessi LLM così ampiamente utilizzati sia per lo sviluppo assistito che per il vibe coding sono
particolarmente propensi a generare codice con bug. Nello specifico le ricerche hanno dimostrato che
nelle operazioni di creazione, quindi non parliamo di completare una o più righe iniziate dallo
sviluppatore ma di scrivere blocchi interi ex novo, il tasso di generazione di codice buggato
è circa uguale a quello di generazione di codice corretto. In altre parole ci azzeccano la metà
delle volte. A questo fatto aggiungiamo poi che gli stessi LLM risultano essere, da un altro studio
sempre recentissimo, questa volta di Microsoft, notevolmente carenti nella capacità di eseguire
il debug del codice. Secondo gli autori della ricerca, infatti, le IA raramente riescono a
completare anche solo metà del processo di debugging e questo perché, secondo loro, nei dati
di addestramento dei modelli attuali non sono presenti abbastanza informazioni che rappresentino
i processi decisionali sequenziali, cioè il modo in cui gli umani fanno debug. Quanto detto finora
quindi, dovrebbe essere sufficiente a far decadere l'idea che sottoponendo all'infinito in bug al
modello e cercando di aggirare i problemi, con il VibeCoding si possa mai arrivare ad un codice
stabile e senza bug. Quindi passiamo al secondo motivo. Da quanto si legge in tanti articoli
sul VibeCoding sembrerebbe, qualcuno l'ha proprio scritto, che esso permetta alle figure che ideano
un prodotto software di realizzarne un prototipo senza alcuna necessità di coinvolgere il team di
sviluppo. Questo prototipo verrebbe generato in tempi brevi e modificato e convalidato interagendo
direttamente col cliente per poi, una volta accettato, essere passato agli sviluppatori
per la vera e propria realizzazione. Ok, questa è una cosa che potrebbe pensare solo chi non ha mai
sviluppato un software per professione. Nel mondo reale non ha alcun senso che un commerciale e un
cliente si accordino sull'acquisto di un software se prima non è stato fatto almeno uno studio di
fattibilità da parte dello sviluppatore. Escludere chi sviluppa dal processo di
prototipazione è semplicemente la ricetta per il disastro. Se infatti il cliente dovesse accettare,
nessuno garantisce che quanto gli sia stato promesso sia effettivamente realizzabile e
con quanto sforzo. C'è il rischio che le risorse necessarie per la realizzazione siano tali da
rendere il prodotto eccessivamente costoso o lungo da realizzare. E anche qui, se c'è qualche folle
là fuori che pensa di poter chiedere sempre all'IA uno studio di fattibilità o una stima su
tempi e costi... beh, in descrizione trovi un po' di esempi di allucinazioni a causa delle quali vari
modelli anche specializzati hanno inventato la qualunque, da parole irlandesi a precedenti
legali passando per anamnesi mediche. Pensa un po' tu se non potrebbero inventarsi tempi e costi
per la realizzazione di un progetto totalmente a caso. E poi ancora, un problema a cui nessuno
pensa tranne gli sviluppatori è che negli ultimi anni il volume del codice sta crescendo in maniera
esponenziale. Sempre più codice da archiviare, da visionare, da tenere al sicuro da furto e da
backdoor o da attacchi alla catena delle dipendenze eccetera. E questo ha un costo. L'utilizzo delle
AI ha già mostrato un incremento nel volume del codice rispetto a quello prodotto da umani. E se
ci aggiungiamo anche che nel vibe coding nessuno si occupa o nemmeno si interessa di andare a
controllare cosa è stato generato, il problema ovviamente non può che peggiorare. E infine,
ma non meno importante, c'è la questione della qualità del codice. Sì, perché magari non tutti
lo sanno, ma un codice che risolve un qualche problema può essere sviluppato in tanti modi
diversi e a diversi livelli qualitativi. Normalmente la qualità, la sicurezza e l'affidabilità vengono
verificate dagli sviluppatori tramite test, code review e altre operazioni manuali o costruite
ad hoc per le varie funzioni. Ma ora la mia domanda è, quanto può saperne un umano della qualità e
della sicurezza del software prodotto da un modello AI se si limita solamente a dialogare
con quest'ultimo senza mai visionare il codice?
Come già detto in precedenza, la mia impressione è che il VibeCoding non sia stato affatto
diffuso nel più chiaro dei modi da alcuni, e che per questo motivo sia stato poi frainteso
a catena da molti altri. C'è infatti chi sembra applicare la definizione VibeCoding
a qualsiasi forma di scrittura di codice supportata dall'intelligenza artificiale, e questo crea
da un lato confusione e dall'altro difficoltà nel valutare correttamente la situazione.
In realtà ciò che Carpati cerca di esprimere nel famoso tweet è che il VibeCoding consiste
specificamente nell'accettare incondizionatamente il codice prodotto dall'LLM, e questo senza
neanche visionarlo. Ciò rende il VibeCoding una strategia molto diversa dallo sviluppare
software avvalendosi del supporto di una IA in modo responsabile, che è invece un
processo che richiede un notevole controllo sul codice da parte dello sviluppatore. In
un flusso di questo tipo, infatti, l'umano descrive comunque la propria richiesta e riceve
una risposta dalla macchina, ma poi deve valutarla approfonditamente prima di integrarla all'interno
della propria codebase. L'idea alla base dello sviluppo assistito, in effetti, è che il codice
prodotto da una macchina potrebbe potenzialmente avere mille difetti e cose che non vanno. Ed è
per questo motivo che io considero responsabilità dello sviluppatore verificarlo prima di accettarlo.
Nell'output dell'LLM potrebbero esserci degli errori o una soluzione proposta potrebbe non
risolvere correttamente il problema. L'impostazione del codice potrebbe non essere in linea con le
convenzioni del progetto, potrebbero venire introdotti dei bug, perfino il codice potrebbe
non essere sufficientemente chiaro e questo introdurrebbe una serie di problemi per la
futura manutenzione. Assumendo poi una visione un po' più ampia, la risposta di un LLM potrebbe
non essere compatibile con future implementazioni che sono state già progettate e pianificate,
cosa che il modello non può sapere considerare. Insomma, la questione alla fine è semplice.
L'intervento umano nella scrittura del codice è ancora indispensabile se si vuole produrre
del software di qualità. Ma nemmeno anche se solo si vuole produrre codice che funziona tutte le
volte e non solo la maggior parte di esse. La verità che in tanti ancora non capiscono o che
si ostinano a non voler considerare è che il lavoro di uno sviluppatore di software non è
solo quello di sfornare codice e funzionalità. Noi sviluppatori scriviamo il codice per far sì
che funzioni in modo definito e dimostrabile e che possa essere compreso non solo dalle macchine
ma anche da altri esseri umani, perché esso deve essere ispezionabile e deve supportare sviluppi
futuri in maniera continuativa. Noi consideriamo cose come le prestazioni, l'accessibilità,
la sicurezza, la manutenibilità, l'efficienza dei costi, i progetti futuri, le risorse attuali.
L'ingegneria del software è una questione di comprensione, risoluzione e soprattutto
compromessi. Il compito di uno sviluppatore è quello di scegliere tra decine di potenziali
soluzioni bilanciando una molteplicità di requisiti che possono essere sia espliciti
ma anche e soprattutto impliciti. E poi, permettimi di essere anche un po' poetico,
programmare per me è esplorare di continuo nuovi mondi e creare qualcosa di nuovo all'interno di
ciascuno di essi. Spesso un qualcosa che nessuno mai prima di me ha realizzato in quel modo.
Programmare è indagare problemi e risolverli utilizzando il proprio ingegno. E nel farlo,
non solo si produce qualcosa, ma si cresce anche imparando cose, comprendendo fatti,
unendo i fili e scoprendo connessioni nascoste. Spesso si torna a casa, anche se io lavoro,
sono in smart working, quindi da casa difficilmente mi sposto, con un'ampia
comprensione del problema e della soluzione realizzata. Una comprensione più ampia e
più profonda di chiunque altro.
Schiarita un po' la situazione, però, mi sento anche di non voler demonizzare al 100%
il vibecoding. Io ho sempre pensato che l'accesso agli strumenti informatici dovesse essere
possibile per tutti. Pensieri in codice è un po' il mio contributo a quest'idea,
e forse il vibecoding potrebbe rappresentare una possibilità in questo senso. Ci sono
là fuori persone che svolgono ogni giorno compiti estremamente noiosi e soprattutto
ripetitivi. Uno strumento che dia loro la possibilità di automatizzarli, anche se
non in modo perfetto, non potrebbe che farmi piacere. Il problema maggiore nel mondo dello
sviluppo software, lo sappiamo tutti, è la curva di apprendimento. Prendiamo il pincopallino
qualsiasi che ha il suo noiosissimo flusso di dati manuale. Se volesse automatizzarlo,
dovrebbe o spendere una cifra notevole facendosi seguire da un professionista, oppure impiegare
tanto del proprio tempo ad imparare un linguaggio di programmazione o un qualche altro strumento.
Io, personalmente, mi metterei a studiare perché mi piace, ma non è detto che tanti
altri debbano pensarla per forza allo stesso modo. Allora perché dovrebbe essere un male
che queste persone abbiano a disposizione un metodo per creare i propri semplici e personali
automatismi? Ovviamente, occhio che qui la parola fondamentale è personali, perché
il VibeCoding può andar bene al massimo per fare esperimenti o sviluppare un progettino
della domenica, che non coinvolga in alcun modo aspetti importanti. Ma se si rispettano
questi limiti, perché no? Basta che non si parli di dati, di soldi, di privacy, di sicurezza o,
in generale, di software che potrebbero essere usati da altri al di fuori di chi le ha creati.
Insomma, per progetti personali, totalmente innocui e a bassissimo impatto, allora un po'
di VibeCoding ci potrebbe anche stare. A parte questa, però, onestamente non vedo
altre applicazioni pratiche reali. Ho letto di tanti che hanno scritto che il VibeCoding
potrebbe portare vantaggi ai programmatori esperti che hanno l'istinto di individuare
i problemi nei test anche senza leggere il codice, ma non mi sembra una teoria che possa
reggere. Dopo 20 anni e oltre di sviluppo, ho imparato a giudicare il codice quasi a colpo
d'occhio. Infatti, sfrutto abitualmente e proficuamente il supporto di varie LLM. Ma,
anche se vedessi dei possibili problemi in un test, come li risolverei senza andare a mettere
le mani nel codice? Dovrei farlo per forza! E siccome l'unica differenza tra VibeCoding e
sviluppo assistito da IEA è proprio andare a guardare il codice, in tal caso non starei
più facendo VibeCoding e quindi la tesi iniziale di tutto il discorso è facilmente smentita. Stessa
identica cosa vale poi per tutte quelle affermazioni tipo il VibeCoding ha il potenziale per aumentare
significativamente la produttività, oppure il VibeCoding permette alle aziende di essere più
competitive. No, assolutamente no. Ma ce lo vedi un team di sviluppo aziendale a fare VibeCoding?
Che accadrebbe se al momento di fare emerge del codice dei vari membri venissero fuori dei
conflitti? Chi li risolverebbe se nessuno sa come funziona il codice scritto? C'è perfino chi si è
spinto a dire che il VibeCoding potrebbe essere usato per affinare l'istinto degli sviluppatori
a riconoscere gli errori prodotti dall'IA e fargli capire che cosa un LLM può o non può fare
bene. Ora, a parte il fatto che gli sviluppatori senior in generale già si allenano abbondantemente
con le code review dei junior e non credo abbiano bisogno di ulteriore palestra in merito, ma poi,
per sviluppare l'istinto, loro hanno affrontato anni di sviluppo lambiccandosi il cervello sul
codice. Se pensassimo veramente di includere il VibeCoding nel processo professionale, come
cambierebbe il metodo di apprendimento? Col passare del tempo, chi sarebbe più veramente in
grado di verificarlo questo codice? La verità è che, come professionisti, abbiamo bisogno di
leggere il codice. Per una programmazione di qualità non va inserito alcun codice nei repository se noi
stessi non siamo in grado come minimo di spiegare a qualcun altro esattamente cosa fa. In più,
l'ottimo sarebbe che la codebase non necessitasse di essere spiegata ad un altro sviluppatore ma
che fosse sufficientemente chiara da permettere a questi di interpretarla autonomamente. Il codice
dovrebbe essere sempre sistemato e pulito. E questo processo, ormai lo abbiamo capito,
non è VibeCoding. Il VibeCoding è una possibilità e come tale non va esclusa a priori ma messa in
pratica solo dopo averne valutato attentamente i pro e i contro. Non è un boost di produttività,
non è un moltiplicatore di qualità, è solo un accesso estremamente semplificato alla realizzazione
di cose estremamente semplici. Può essere un buon metodo per produrre qualcosa di temporaneo o poco
importante se usata bene ma se usata male diventa subito un generatore di problemi e di debito
tecnico.
the
Bene, ti ho raccontato la mia sul VibeCoding. Sono sicuro che ci sarà là fuori chi avrà
opinioni diverse dalle mie e mi piacerebbe conoscerle, quindi non esitare a scrivermi
a valerio-pensierincodice.it con due i, a lasciare un commento ove possibile tipo su
YouTube o Spotify o a unirti al gruppo Telegram del podcast dove troverai tante altre persone
interessanti. Intanto io ringrazio l'amico Davide Fasoli di Insider dentro la tecnologia
per averci prestato la voce per leggere il tweet di Carpati. Se non conosci Insider,
beh sappi che è uno dei podcast fissi del mio feed. Ogni settimana propone un escursus
su un argomento tecnologico attualissimo spaziando dall'intelligenza artificiale all'aeronautica
militare. Mi raccomando, lo trovi su tutte le principali piattaforme podcast e in più
ti lascio il link al sito ufficiale in descrizione. Come sempre poi ringrazio coloro che ormai
sono di diritto i produttori esecutivi di Pensieri in Codice, Edoardo e Carlo. Loro
due ogni mese con la loro donazione incarnano di fatto lo spirito treasure del value for
value. Value for value, ti ricordo, vuol dire che se stai ascoltando Pensieri in Codice,
se magari hai ascoltato tutte le puntate, se addirittura sei lì a chiederti quando
uscirà il prossimo episodio, beh, allora non puoi negare che questo progetto ha un po'
di valore per te. Quanto vale? Non lo so. Questo lo decidi tu. E poi una volta che avrai
una risposta, mi sembra giusto che tu restituisca una minima parte di questo valore. Al prossimo
progetto, non a me. Time, talent and treasure. Magari decidi che vale un po' del tuo tempo.
E allora parliamo della risorsa time della filosofia value for value.
In tal caso restituisci valore condividendo gli episodi, parlandone ad amici, parenti,
colleghi, al macellaio appassionato di informatica, insomma, a chi pensi che possa piacere.
Oppure, magari puoi decidere che pensieri in codice valga un po' del tuo talent.
Talento nel fare cosa?
Non lo so, proponiti.
A me, lo ripeto almeno da qualche episodio, piacerebbe tanto aprire degli account social
e iniziare a condividere spezzoni, news e roba così.
Purtroppo, però, non ho né le competenze né il tempo per mettere su tutto, ti andrebbe
di darmi una mano?
Non serve essere il guru dei social, già aprire e fare un po' di attività sarebbe
un enorme passo avanti.
Dai, su che per quanto mi impegni da solo, difficilmente riuscirò a far crescere il
progetto.
Dai, lo so che sei lì, ma fino ad ora non ti sei ancora fatto avanti perché magari
ti vergogno, pensi di non essere all'altezza, ma non è così.
Scrivimi, io sono qui.
E infine c'è Treasure, che sta banalmente per donazioni.
Quindi, se ti va di restituire un po' di valore in questo modo, trovi i link sia in
descrizione che sul sito pensieriincodice.it, sempre con due i.
Detto questo, io ti ringrazio per aver ascoltato fin qui, ti saluto e ti ricordo sempre che
un informatico risolve problemi, a volte anche usando il computer.